welcome to this video playing conceited
set a title player we'll see I've played
him once and lost so don't you get on
the scoreboard it's not playing James
Holland feeder 2252 okay with a funky
picture so I'm going for a Sicilian just
want to have some and some other
positions I've played a lot of you 45
recently and a little bit of variety is
interesting this is something that I
have to admit don't know well but why
not yeah it just blitz I had this on the
port just recently idea i spent ages to
try to figure out if i can take if or
not this time i'm just playing a movie 6
and develop the other coming on 85 is a
somewhat unusual spot fallen for a
position like that ok maybe take it
bishops is sex with the Queen on g3 and
if 5 is not possible look f to you want
ok that's somewhat surprising
so hmm seems he wants to play the a rock
and 2d one why not that was my idea
lining up there I'm still not
threatening to take anything even if he
goes screen g3 Wow yeah well this is
probably not objectively good but it
splits share so he wants to go well
that's an interesting question if I want
to ok I'm going to do that maybe he can
play a 5 I mean I was thinking it's
probably not possible as g5 hangs but
these six of was hanging as well yeah
he's going for it but
hmm ok I cannot go e5 if we start with
some some other moves ok let's take this
is not ideal it's really not ideal that
kind of justifies his his play
mmm absolutely not idea especially now
if he takes on e6 besides some M
tactical issues that might be there
immediately he also after e6 no one does
that okay after it six faults there is
also yeah the issue that the night can
come to the five which is some jogger
which is something that with 86 because
I wanted to drive the night back now and
this is not happening now check
night too if five is still sealed
something when his king is super super
open i mean let's do this 495 is he just
going to five himself opening up the
diagonal no but this huh it should be
good for me 93 check and the queen is
ready to go over like we need seven
Queen yeah his keys king is very and
secure
nine f3m look everyone I guess to give
up the exchange
no I don't know that looks pretty awful
yeah I think I was thinking that he
probably has to do that yeah I wonder if
I want to take it in the first place
that's early I cam yeah I think I will
didn't see a good alternative I'm still
attacking it's not like I'm giving up my
attack sometimes you have to be a bit
reluctant to do to grab material if you
have a have an attack going and then you
grab a pawn or something and give up on
your initiative this is something that
absolutely should be avoided but if you
feel like you you keep the attack going
then there is no big reason to avoid
material gains yeah so here I'm going to
check I guess drop down to the edge of
the board and now look f-84 look f1
trying to keep playing with threats you
see porn is dangerously ok got this n
how to do that look aged six queen age
six maybe i would like to play with more
threats queen on the long diagonal would
be cool but that wouldn't work time
morning okay let's go here I mean I'm I
have certain rook f2 so it's not like
this is no threat at all and the Queen
has to probably watch over they have one
square create h3 is also an idea
threatening rogue f1 I have to watch out
for the back rank also a little bit and
then it's no silly Queen takes f3 all of
a sudden and I'm checkmated on the back
rank yeah i was just about just about
thinking of this move but Queen age
three looks like a good reply
threatening or everyone and let's do
that kingi wonders Queen g4 that wins
very clearly yeah yeah I think that's it
if you move that night detour so I have
look f2
it doesn't cover g2 and h2 now quite
resigned okay I was a win for the
Sicilian yeah I don't know I'm not a
northern opening expert here i'm just
playing it for some variety I know that
this is this is kind of normal but yeah
yeah and if in an earlier game I was
really spending some time there to check
if I can take that pawn but ultimately I
recognize that this happens and I'm
threatened on f7 and on c6 so that
Knight f6 you can take here now the
engine is actually showing that this is
a move as I'm looking at the bishop so
the engine wants to do that desperado
right here white is bad i am of course
me so probably this is not so bad what
I'm doing now it oh you have no idea how
to assess is but it looks like quite
normal play I was surprised about this
move normally you go rook a to e 1 and
this kind of structure to support both
pawns and not puts you don't put
something on the D file quite often you
kind of expect that the F file opens at
some point so you keep the rook there so
bit surprising ok B 5 is not great
because now why to miss this move that's
very nice one this is unprotected so if
i take take it's very awkward this is of
me okay by the pond hanging and this is
hanging and I don't have any have a
great move so that was a good
opportunity of him well I can I can do
here yet this is what the engine is
giving but it's not exactly what I
wanted in three you know I went back to
put the Queen on p 7
engine gives this and probably this is
better now if I get in before in the
better circumstance it's probably
probably preferable yeah g5 was a really
really aggressive move but it seems to
be good seems to be okay this was the
best that I could come up with and it
felt awkward I think that by the way now
he played this move and well I think
that he just if he takes it if he just
takes it and i'm not sure what now just
just something usual or something i
don't what is the computer game we here
to attack this okay yeah and here now
that's kind of comparable to the game
actually but maybe in assists it's
probably of Eva's a better version I
have got more time now I've gained time
IAM here and maybe they're the next move
only is the problem we'll get one now is
given by the computer by weather with a
slight advantage but have upon whatever
that means in this position I mean I
actually think that the computer email
evaluation might be might be correct but
in a human player blitz game the white
position is not easy to handle s is cut
you know absolutely no porn cover and
well it's a poem but the porn that white
has is like this porn or this one and
they are not very relevant to the
position at the moment this is sometimes
um yeah approached in a wrong way by by
players I think okay I'm a pawn up and
porn upgrade but the extra porn itself
is not contributing to the position very
much yeah this is a different thing to
let's say you have an extra porn it is a
it's a passed pawn of the sixth-ranked
that it's close to promoting it maybe em
gang ties down opponents pieces then
their pawn actually has a very real
relevance for the next couple of moves
and this is not the case here the whites
one is get a potential asset for the
endgame but in an in a middle game the
bad King position has to be handled
correctly and this is not easy in blitz
team I immediately and went wrong I
guess with that in 1995 I'm winning chan
onion it's not just the material it's
also that okay and that the activity is
excellent 13 inch six and okay I think
I'm keeping a win here in hand right
yeah the engine gives thought
improvement a queen f voice even quicker
and I take a minus 3 and probably if it
calculates a little bit longer this well
this will climb so um yeah a good way
nothing can not Sicilian here and there
is entertaining so i will i will play it
some cases yeah thanks for watching